l'achat fait partie du groupe la route
d'argent qui défend la cause des
prostituées à saint-pétersbourg dans
cette v plus de 7000 travailleuses du
sexe sont inscrits cette ong
[Musique]
macha fait le tour de ce qu'on appelle
les salons comme ici où les prostituées
se regroupent
elle leur apporte des préservatifs leur
offre des tests de dépistage du vih et
autres soins de santé le tout se déroule
dans la plus grande discrétion la
prostitution ici est illégale au local
de la route d'argent
deux jeunes femmes veulent devenir
travailleuse du sexe
cette conseillère leur demande ils
savent ce qu'est le sida
elles répondent que non s'en suit un
cours de base sur cette maladie pourtant
connue depuis des années 80 irina masse
trouva a créé la route d'argent en 2003
elle a été elle-même prostituée pendant
six ans pour elle la russie connaît une
épidémie du sida parce qu'on refuse de
voir la réalité en face sa massette
faire botoxer cette initiation au
traîneau de tout ce qui est relié au
sexe ici est criminel et est interdit
par la loi
c'est ce que l'état ne veut pas
comprendre ces gens ont plutôt besoin
d'être protégés soigner ses stats c'est
la tâche de l'état de faire en sorte que
l'épidémie s'arrête à cette génération
dans la rue on off ouvertement des
filles à 11 100 roubles 24 dollars
malgré l'interdiction de la prostitution
la rose d'argent reçoit entre autres
l'aide du groupe juridique canadien
vih/sida et lina masse nova communique
régulièrement avec michael griffin qu à
toronto qui a mis sur pied un réseau de
huit juristes russe pour défendre les
droits des prostituées des homosexuels
des toxicomanes à travers la russie
en fait les gens qui font usage de
drogues sont considérés comme des
criminels et tous les moyens pour les
traités sont illégaux ça les rend
complètement vulnérables au vih et à
l'hépatite c en russie ce qui favorise
l'épidémie de vih c'est l'oppression et
violations des droits de l'homme au gant
c'est pour ça que l'aide juridique est
devenu essentiel à la vie
contre les synergies ailleurs à saint
pétersbourg ce bus du groupe action
humanitaire fait le tour des quartiers
de banlieue pour fournir de l'aide aux
toxicomanes
même si c'est mal vu par les autorités
oui s'ils reçoivent l'aide du groupe
juridique canadien vih/sida
ici on retrouve la moitié des nouveaux
cas de sida chez ceux qui s'injectent
des drogues
la plupart des patients sont dans un
très mauvais état
ils ont différentes maladies le sida
l'hépatite b et c il y à des cas de
syphilis mais dans la plupart des cas
c'est le sida il y a aussi des
infections non soignée il ne désinfecte
pas leurs seringues miller dans le reste
du monde on utilise des traitements de
substitution comme la méthadone pour
sevrer ses utilisateurs de drogues en
russie méthadone reste illégal il ya en
russie un million et demi d'individus
séropositifs ou atteints du sida
le taux d'infection continue d'augmenter
de 10 à 15 % par année
[Musique]
ici les médias par le peu de ce grave
problème et puis depuis des années les
campagnes d'information publique
décrivent comme seule arme pour
combattre le sida
l'abstinence ou la fidélité et pendant
ce temps là mais l'onu et des ong
préviennent que la russie va droit vers
la catastrophe vers une épidémie
généralisée d'ici 2021
si rien n'est fait si on ne change pas
d'attitude face à cette maladie
et si raymond st-pierre radio canada à
saint pétersbourg